تعرف في مكان غير معروف ، يأخذنا
ضابط المخابرات العسكرية الأوكراني
أليكس سي لرؤية أحد
أحدث التهديدات لروسيا في ساحة المعركة ، وهي
طائرة بدون طيار إيرانية الصنع تُعرف باسم مهاجا
6 ، وهي كبيرة
يستخدمها الروس للاستطلاع
والقصف ،
نعم ، لقد تم إطلاق النار عليها.  هذه
الحفرة من حيث أسقطتها ، نعم
هذه مكالمة من صاروخ
القوات الأوكرانية يمكنك رؤية صفر اثنين أه
2022. لذلك هذا هو التاريخ الذي
صنعت فيه ، نعتقد أن هذه الطائرة صنعت
في هذا العام عندما  بدأ الروس في
إطلاق هذه الطائرات بدون طيار ، لدينا مشاكل جديدة في الميدان في
ساحة المعركة ،
وآخرها
136 طائرة بدون طيار كاميكازي شهيد تحطم
البنية التحتية المدنية وترويع
الناس العاديين
، قال الكرملين اليوم إن المعدات الروسية فقط
بأرقام روسية مستخدمة
في ما يسمى بالعملية الخاصة ولكن
يقول الكسيس إنه لا يوجد شك من أين
تأتي هذه الطائرة بدون طيار من الآن. لا أرى أي
كتابة بالفارسية باللغة الإيرانية.
كيف تعرف
أننا نعلم أنها جيش التحرير الشعبى الصينى الإيرانية  من خلال
شيئين أساسيين ، أول شيء
شاهدناه في معارض الطائرات في
الدول الأخرى وقبل بضع سنوات
إيرانية شركاتهم أظهرت
هذا بالضبط
هذه الطائرة والشيء الثاني لماذا قمنا
بزيارة الطائرة الإيرانية نعم لدينا
كتابة واحدة فقط  مكتوب بواسطة قنبهم ،
هل يمكنك أن تُظهر لي نعم جيدًا ،
لذا فهذه هي الفارسية ، أعتقد نعم ، أنت على حق
[موسيقى]
هناك تقول إنهم حاولوا
إخفاء الحقائق ، نعم ، لقد
دعوت إلى مزيد من
العزاء ضد قوة إيران التي تطير
المخدرات لذا  حتى الآن
كان لها تأثير ضئيل ، المكونات
متوفرة تجاريًا في عدد من
البلدان المختلفة من
البطاريات اليابانية إلى المحرك النمساوي والمعالجات الأمريكية ،
هذا هو مهاجا ستة الآن نشاهد
هذه الطائرات بدون طيار كاميكازي رأس شاه
136 وأنت تقول أن هناك جيلًا جديدًا  من
الطائرات بدون طيار قادمة إلى Arash Arash II نعم
كثيرًا من هذا